this is major Roy McBride I'm attempting  to reach dr. Clifford McBride this is  dr. McBride Sonia  dad I'd like to see Union  [Music]  I recall how we used to watch  black/white movies together musicals  were your favorite  I remember you tutoring me in math he  was tilden me a strong work ethic  you should know I've chosen a career  that you would approve of I've dedicated  my life to the exploration of space and  I thank you for that  [Music]  what is happening out there is a crisis  of unknown magnitude  [Music]  we believe your father may be involved  my father's dead what exactly are you  implying for me  exploration is know is a noble venture  we have to hold out the possibility that  your father may be hiding from us  we have a job to do are you ready and  ready  [Music]  you  [Music]  you